in many ways Canadians 15 over are doing
well Keith Newman co-author of a new
report about aging in Canada says it's
getting harder to plan for retirement
among those who are working and and
intending to retire because not all are
only a third feel confident that they
can afford to when they want to 70% of
Canadians over 50 are worried about the
rising cost of living according to the
report and nearly half worry about
running out of money adding to concerns
is a big decline that we've seen in
coverage by workplace pension plans in
the 1970s approximately half of all
Canadians had access to workplace
pensions but now it's only about oneir
that means a shrinking safety net as
costs rise the ni's natal chashi tells
us the current situation puts Canadians
and the owners on Canadians to use
private savings as a way to fund their
retirement now Canadians are living
longer than ever before so unlike in the
past that means that they need to be
able to Finance longer periods of
retirement and we also know that the
current economic climate makes it very
challenging for many Canadians to save
for those on the cusp of retirement
economic uncertainty is making it harder
than ever to plan ahead be more wealth
adviser Leander Roo tells us that is the
main conversation that I seem to be
having with our clients on a regular
basis it's becoming unaffordable for
Canadians to feel confident about their
retirement and what their later years in
life will look like and I do think that
we will need the government to step up
and provide some additional support in
that area for the people who can't
afford nangali Global News Toronto